and
relaxing releasing particularly the calf
muscle
as as he's starting to get the ground
vector as i'm starting to establish the
ground vector on the back foot
come on don't loosen up okay i try to
relax that back flow
next drill we came on both sides of the
body you can put more pressure on me
and i'm gonna do the same thing release
as as the back foot is getting weighted
release the calf muscle
and then the next drill was to walk
with that same releasing skill so
release
release the cap release the calf cap
uh obviously this is not it
and this forward is just bracing
but if you want to move forward even
establishing
the yang on the next foot and then going
isn't quite the same thing so
uh i could be like this he's pushing
and i could walk like this he still
can't stop
the pain
okay so remember
the young foot bringing the knees to the
toe
and then establishing the ground vector
now on the front foot
is a phase but it's a beginner phase
okay so if you want
your movement is just he's pushing
your movement is just natural
hence my demonstration that i can stand
straight
i could even lean backwards to show
i don't need to do this okay
all right let's go okay so
um
what you're trying to do up till now is
not push on him
to let his energy go by okay
so i'm not bracing against him
so already his energy is passing through
me so
technically as he as he weighs my back
foot his energy is going past me
so technically i am not pushing against
his energy
otherwise it would not go down on the
ground
so technically i'm already in a state of
non-contestation
this is the more sophisticated form as
opposed to he's coming in
and usually that's non-contestation too
because his energy's going young and i
go yin
true
but if you keep it yang and yin aspects
or perspective
the same thing's happening here his
energy is going through me that
that's why i don't need and i don't need
anything push
i don't need anything don't don't need
the other leg
that's why i can walk like this he's not
pushing on me
he's pushing on the ground you could do
whatever
so now we'll go into tenshi nage and i'm
not doing an
external non-contestation because
here as you go young
you're keeping him out which is what we
usually do
so we keep him out boom and then
so i'm gonna do the same walking drill
keep the same internal non-contest
station
and you'll see how he comes really far
forward
you see that's what we're testing
forget the throw part it's the
it's the yin part this non-contestation
internally in
you could forget the throw
this is external now external pushing
we want to load him so he loads
forget the thrill part see how high you
can get up on your
on your channel
that's the test
you feel how very relaxed
internally even her that stopped
still came in more than she wanted to
same thing
same thing there okay even the uk that
doesn't want to come in once they feel
the void
you came in about two inches more than
you wanted to
okay so uh
i established a non-contest station
internally so
right now i'm not contesting his energy
is going through me
it's true i'm not moving but his energy
is not clashing with my energy
that's why this is all goofy relaxed
okay
i now move this over
and start the rotation and over here
i am in the center of the technique i am
in the center of the back
outward position okay
i'm eventually going to enter
that's young energy to harmonize with
him
he must already be yin which means he
must already be
uh he must stop his forward progress
for me to enter in a harmonious way
i cannot enter to start his
backwards movement that's a clash
okay so this is
a clash
then he doesn't come as far forward
so when i now contest internally
move to the center of the spot where it
comes forward and you can see
our energy is already going back from
the spirals
boom comes forward
and i am staying with a body that is
already going backwards
that's why there's not a big gap but i'm
not pushing him backwards
it's not this is pushing him back
that's a clash so
disappear he's falling and i'm
keeping the connection let's just do
that i'm still not doing tenshi nugget
i'm just working wait for the yin
generate the end
stay with him don't gap don't let a gap
out
the boom comes in way
you want to come in
okay try